CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I
really just want
to practice matrix
multiplication, which
is potentially something
new for some of you,
and maybe some of you have
been doing it for a while
and are very good at it.
But I want to make sure that
everyone is feeling confident
in their ability to
multiply matrices.
So we have three matrices here.
We have A, B, and C. And
what I want you to do
is I want you to compute
what makes sense below.
I have four products
of matrices below.
a is A times B, b is B
times A, c is B times C,
and d is A times
C. So I want you
to multiply the matrices
that make sense to multiply,
and then the ones that don't,
make sure you understand why.
Give yourself a
brief explanation
of why you can't multiply them.
So why don't you work on
that, pause the video,
and when you feel
confident in your answers,
bring the video back up, and you
can check them against my work.
OK, welcome back.
Well, we wanted to make sure
we felt comfortable multiplying
matrices.
So what we're going to do
is look at the four products
I mentioned below, and we're
going to see how they do,
whether or not we can
actually compute them.
So let's first look
at a, which was
A times B. So before
I write it down again,
A times B is-- notice A is a
2 by 2 matrix, and B is a 2
by 3 matrix, right?
And so if I write letter
a, we know we're taking a 2
by 2 by a 2 by 3.
And so the fact that the
interior dimensions agree,
that the number
of columns of A is
equal to the number
of rows of B,
means that I can multiply them.
So I can multiply them, and
my result I expect to get
is, of course, the dimensions
we have on the outside.
So I expect to get
a 2 by 3 matrix.
So I'm going to
rewrite A and B here,
so that I don't have to
keep walking back and forth,
and then we'll do
the multiplication.
So I have [6, 5; 1, 2]
times [2,  -1, 3; 1, 0, 4].
OK.
So I want to perform
this multiplication.
Now remember that
when you are looking
for a value in your resulting
matrix, which I know is 2 by 3,
so I can even make a
little space for myself.
I know it's 2 by 3,
so I know I'm going
to have to fill in these spots.
When I look at this position,
it's row 1, column 1.
That means I take row
1 of the first matrix,
and I'm essentially
just dotting it
with column 1 of
the second matrix.
So I'm taking row 1 times column
1 in the way it was described,
which is I take 6 times 2,
and I add it to 5 times 1.
So row 1, column 1 gives me
6 times 2 is 12, plus 5 times
1 which is 5, so I get 17.
And then if I come in to
the next spot, what is this?
And the resulting matrix's
position is row 1, column 2.
So now I take row 1
of the first matrix
and column 2 of
the second matrix,
and I get 6 times negative 1
is negative 6, plus 0 times 5,
so I get a negative 6 here.
Negative 6 times 0.
Maybe I should
show you this way.
Negative 6 times 0.
OK.
And then here I am now in the
third spot of the first row,
so I'm in a row 1, column 3.
So that's again, row 1 of the
first, column 3 of the second.
So you see a pattern here about
where we're getting our things
from that we're multiplying.
For row 1, column
3 of the resulting,
I take row 1 of the first
and column 3 of the second.
So 6 times 3 is 18,
plus-- 5 times 4 is 20.
So 20 plus 18 is 38.
OK.
Now I have to do the
same thing on the bottom.
Right?
So I have now here, the
row, notice I'm in row 2,
so I'm always going to use
row 2 of this first matrix.
And then what we
saw last time is I
used column 1 in the
first spot, column 2
in the second spot, column
3 in the third spot.
Right?
That's what happens
over and over again.
So what do I do?
I take [1, 2], and I
multiply it by [2, 1].
So I take 1 times
2, plus 2 times 1.
So I get 2 there and
2 there, so I get a 4.
And then the next
column: row 2, column 2.
1 times negative 1 is
negative 1-- 2 times 0
is 0-- so I get a negative 1.
And then the last column.
1 times 3 is 3.
2 times 4 is 8.
So I get 3 plus 8, so I get 11.
Hopefully I didn't make any
stupid summing mistakes there,
but if I did, you
probably caught it.
Because I was trying to
say what I did as we went.
So that is the answer to a.
OK.
So now let's think
about what is b.
b was take B times A, which
is just to switch the order.
So let's look at the
dimension match-up.
Now we have a 2 by
3 matrix, and I'm
trying to multiply it
by a 2 by 2 matrix.
Well, I don't have
to do any more work,
because I can't do it.
Because the dimensions of the
insides here-- three columns
for B, two rows for A--
means that I can't actually
multiply them.
OK?
So this isn't even defined.
OK, so that was easy.
That was b.
All right.
Letter c-- I'll give
myself a lot of room
to do that-- letter
c was B times C.
And so I'm going to
write down the dimensions
to see if I even need to
write down the matrices.
B was two rows by
three columns, and C
was three rows by two columns.
So if I look at the dimensions,
the 3 and the 3 match up,
so I am going to be
able to multiply them,
and my result-- as I mentioned
before-- should be a 2 by 2.
So let me write
down B and C here,
so we don't have to
keep going to the side.
OK.
And then C is 1, 2 negative
1; negative 1, 3, 2.
All right, let me just make sure
I didn't transcribe anything
incorrectly.
I think it looks good.
OK.
So row 1 of B. Row 2 of B.
Column 1 of C. Column 2 of C.
We're going to be dealing
with those, specifically.
So we want to multiply these.
We said our resulting matrix
is going to be 2 by 2.
OK.
Because I'm going to
have a lot of terms,
I might write them down on
this one, and then simplify.
Because I may make a mistake,
so to be more careful,
I'll write down all the pieces.
So here I am in row 1,
column 1 of the resulting.
So I take row 1 of the first,
column 1 of the second,
and what do I get
when I multiply?
I get 2 times 1-- that's 2.
Plus negative 1 times
2-- that's negative 2.
Plus 3 times negative
1-- that's negative 3.
Right?
That's all we have to do
for the first position.
Then I do, for the second
one, it's row 1, column 2.
So I do row 1, column 2.
So I'll try to keep my
head out of the way.
I realize I keep
stepping in front.
So it's 2 times negative 1.
I get negative 2.
Negative 1 times 3,
so I get negative 3.
And 3 times 2 gives me 6.
OK.
And then the bottom two.
I get row 2, column
1 over here, and then
row 2, column 2 over here.
So row 2, column 1 is
going to be 1 times 1.
Plus 0 times 2.
Plus 4 times negative
1, so I get negative 4.
And then here.
Row 2, column 2.
I get 1 times negative
1, so I have negative 1.
Plus 0 times 3-- plus 0.
And then 4 times 2 is 8.
So if I simplify these, it
looks like in the first spot
I should get a negative 3.
And the second spot,
I should get a 1.
This is just for you
to check your answer.
And the third spot,
I get a negative 3.
And then the fourth
spot, I get a 7.
So hopefully I added
correctly all throughout.
I think I did, so I
think we're good there.
So that is the answer to c.
And again, the reason
we can multiply those,
was that the dimensions-- when
you wrote them down in order--
the dimensions to
the inside agreed,
and then the outside
gives us the size
of the resulting matrix.
So there was one more
problem, and that was d.
And I wanted you to take A
times C. And A was a 2 by 2.
And C was a 3 by 2.
And so again, we
see we can't do it,
because the two
interior dimensions
here-- when I write them in
that order-- don't agree.
OK.
So d is not defined.
All right, so the basic
idea of this whole video
is just to make sure we
felt comfortable multiplying
matrices.
We're trying to use some simple
examples to understand that.
Understand how we can
recognize from the dimensions
whether or not multiplication
is even defined,
and then what size the
resulting matrix will be.
I do want to point
out one thing.
And I want to point out that
if we come over to our example
back in the beginning.
We had A*B as our first example
and then B*A as our second
example.
And A*B-- well, I think, I got
to remember what they were--
yeah, A*B you could multiply,
but B*A you could not.
So I think it has
been stressed before,
but I think I should
stress it again, that order
matters in multiplication.
OK?
You can't commute these things.
You can't switch the order
and get the same result.
So matrix
multiplication, you have
to be very careful about
keeping things in the same order
as you're multiplying.
OK, I think that is
where I will stop.